[Music]
we still don't know much about Hideo
Kojima's next game but the beloved
developer has teased the mysterious
death stranding once again I'm Matt and
this gamespot news update is like
nothing you've ever watched before
Kojima told BBC News beat that he wants
the game to be something that people can
get into easily before it starts to turn
into something a little different after
an hour or two he said that it's not
like anything we've ever played before
and added that he wants to be seen as a
risk taker but it is important to keep
your expectations in check it's not
uncommon for directors to talk up their
games like this and des training could
end up being much more familiar than
Kojima's letting on Kojima also
discussed how he wants to combine
different forms of entertainment to
engage people who want to experience
more than just the game whether that
means des training will be a mix of
cinema and game is yet to be seen but
the Metal Gear Solid craters games have
been known for their cinematic
approaches we'll keep you updated as
further deaths trending news is revealed
so for that and more from the world of
video games stay tuned to GameSpot's
you